ich heiße sie ganz herzlich willkommen aus dem
haus der religionen in bern seit vier jahren
sind hier acht religionsgemeinschaften
unter einem dach es ist der ideale ort
für die erste ausgabe unser streitfragen da
wollen wir nämlich mit menschen mit gästen
aus verschiedenen religionsgemeinschaften
über strittige themen diskutieren heute ist
es die streitfrage abtreibung ein altes heftig
umstrittenes thema das inzwischen wieder neue
brisanz und aktualität erhalten hat ist es
wichtig ein menschliches leben weg zu machen
um ein problem zu lösen ist es richtig einen
auftragsmörder zu mieten um ein problem zu lösen
es ist nicht richtig menschliches leben
weg zu machen sei es noch so klein
mit diesen worten schreckte franziskus
unlängst viele frauen auf ausgerechnet
der reform papst vergleicht abtreibungen mit
der auftragsmord katholische und feministische
frauenorganisationen während sich mit protesten
und petition gegen die kriminalisierung von
abtreibungen in der schweiz nimmt die zahl
der schwangerschaftsabbrüche er ab doch der
streit rührt an eine grundfrage ist werden das
leben unter allen umständen schützenswert wann
beginnt das menschliche leben mit neuen
medizinischen tests können krankheiten
behinderungen und geschlecht heute sehr früh
erkannt werden viele religiöse traditionen
begegnen der abtreibung mit skepsis gesetzgeber
aber auch die religionsgemeinschaften sind
gefordert ihre haltungen zu überprüfen ja die
haltung verschiedener religionsgemeinschaften
zur streitfrage abtreibung wollen wir
jetzt hier in dieser runde diskutieren
mit anette b klassist jüdische theologin
mit valentin abgottspon er ist freidenker
und atheist und mit christina aus der aussie
ist evangelische theologin herzlich willkommen
das sind von außen betrachtet ist es für viele
so christentum und abtreibung das geht gar nicht
zusammen ist das so na ja zuerst ist es schon
gehört es zu den tiefsten überzeugungen im
christentum dass menschliches leben nicht
nur menschliches leben aber hier auch vor
allem menschliches leben einen wert hat und
eine würde hat ohne eine vorleistung man muss
nicht bestimmte eigenschaften haben man muss
nicht eine bestimmte leistung erbringen um
eine würde zu haben und deswegen ist eine zutiefst
christliche überzeugung leben menschliches leben
ist schützenswert aber gerade protestanten sind
auch der überzeugung dass es die freiheit gibt
den eigenen lebensentwurf zu entwickeln dass
es nicht ein system von dogmen gibt was man
ungesehen es allen überstellten sollte und auch
dass es zur mitmenschlichkeit gehört erst einmal
mit respekt auf den andersdenkenden einzugehen
und von daher eröffnet das ein weites feld für
gespräche und zu sagen es geht nicht zusammen
das ist zu schnell gut wir werden sehen welche
konsequenzen diese position hat frau birthler
wies das aus der sicht des juden als ich denke das
christentum hat von uns übernommen dass das leben
absolut schützenswert ist und heilig im judentum
ist eigentlich der vers auf denen wir uns beziehen
wenn wir über abtreibung diskutieren der berühmte
satz auge um auge zahn um zahn was weniger bekannt
ist ist was vor diesem satz steht da steht nämlich
wenn zwei männer streiten und treffen eine
schwangere frau die da aus irgendwelchen gründen
zufällig stand und sie hat eine fehlgeburt dann
bezahlt er eine strafe als ob das ein eigentums
schaden ist wenn aber ein schaden entsteht dann
gilt neffe start erscheint hat ein leben um leben
auge um auge zahn um zahn das heißt daraus kann
man schliessen was da verloren gegangen ist war
dann wohl noch gar kein leben und daraus entspannt
sich nun eine bunte debatte in viele richtungen
okay das ist halt die grundlage aber sei es
jetzt diese diese stelle aus der bibel für heute
jüdische leben heißt ja wir beziehen uns immer
rück auf die diskussion in der vergangenheit also
die wichtigste nächste stelle ist dann die mischna
das ist das älteste jüdische gesetzbuch in diesem
exodus text also exodus 21 da ging es ja nicht um
abtreibung sondern um so einen dummen zufall dass
da jemand im weg stand in der mischna dasteht
wenn eine frau schwierigkeiten bei einer geburt
hat dann darf man den fötus zerschneiden und
stückweise aus ihr heraus nehmen denn ihr leben
geht vor seinen das ist natürlich die logische
schlussfolgerung dass da ja noch eben vorher
gar kein leben war aber wenn schon die mehrheit
herausgekommen ist dann darf man nicht ein leben
wegen eines anderen lebens zurückdrängen erste
unterscheidung jetzt aber noch valentin abgottspon
glaubens gehört der papst sagt abtreibung nicht zu
vergleichen die auftragsmord ihre reaktion nennt
oder die die medien nennen ihn zu häufig reform
papst ich sehe nicht unsere form papst er ist so
ein selbstbedienungsladen also einerseits ist der
ultra-konservative eben auch bei solchen dingen
was er über homosexualität oder einfach anders
sexualität gesagt hat da muss man auch nicht
zu viel hoffnung hineinsetzen als ob jetzt die
katholische kirche eine reformierte wäre dann wäre
sie reformiert wenn sie das wäre oder würde und
ich sehe da schon viel kritikwürdiges also einfach
zu sagen auftragsmord das ist schon das geht also
schon sehr sehr weit ich finde dann da ist er
häufig ein besserer kirchenaustritts katalysator
als dass ich sein kann aber nehmen wir es noch
vom papst etwas weg zum thema gekommen dass bei
grundsätzlich ist vielleicht ein bisschen ethisch
das heuer auf der falschen bühne oder werden die
begriffe nicht ganz klar gehabt zum beispiel denke
ich ist es auch eine falsche frage ist das leben
also eigentlich lebt auch schon eine eizelle für
sich die frage ist dass menschliches leben ist für
mich auch nicht die relevanteste sondern kann es
leid empfinden kann es schmerzen empfinden und da
geht eigentlich die biologie die medizin und fast
alles davon aus mindestens bis zum 12 12 wochen
nach der empfängnis ist das also unrealistisch
dass es wirklich schon ein schmerzempfinden hat
die abwägung ist wichtig und da wird sind die
diskussion interessant also wo ist das recht
der frau zu entscheiden idealerweise wenn das
machbar ist und eine beziehung da es zu einem mann
soll auch den man mitreden dürfen idealerweise da
fängt es an für mich spannend zu werden für mich
gelten aber keine religiösen gründe eine an ein
konzept wie seele ist dann für mich einfach
nicht gut genug definiert das ist schon die
große auslegeordnung aber ich höre aus für sie
so eine bemerkung einfach viel zu pauschal sie
wollen da die färinger sich also schon sehr frech
also eigentlich ist das schon es ist eine ohrfeige
für ganz ganz viele frauen zurück und visionen
das ja eigentlich widerstand der in verschiedenen
ländern auch in der schweiz bei ihnen ist bereits
angeklungen oder diese lebensschutz auf der einen
seite auf der anderen seite die einzelne situation
aber das richtige haus gehört entscheidung der
frau ich werde eben wirklich sagen die diskussion
beginnt nicht erst bei der frage kann es leider
nicht leiten das ist nur schon philosophisch gibt
es schon eine diskussion vorher also will man die
folgen beurteilen oder will man wie kant zum
beispiel da braucht man gar nicht theologe sein
sagen es gibt gewisse rechte gewisse prinzipien
da geht es nicht um die folgen sondern es ist
schon in sicht falsch und ich glaube beim passt
klar ich schrecke auch zurück wenn er sagt das
ist auftragsmord aber was er auch vorher gesagt
hat darf man ein menschliches leben zerstören
um ein problem zu beseitigen ich glaube schon
dass das etwas bedenkenswert das ist es geht ja
nicht einfach darum dass man einen stein aus dem
weg liegt weil er einem im weg ist sondern was
wir hier tun es diskutieren darüber was machen wir
mit was wollen wir im gesetz haben dass frauen und
männer da gebe ich ihnen sehr recht entscheiden
dürfen über werden das leben dass eventuell ein
mensch werden könnte was passiert da auch in der
gesellschaft und ich finde es wichtig dass man
auch unterstreicht und immer wieder sagt da geht
es um etwas was zutiefst an unsere intuition und
ich bin papst auch das war erstens dass er da
noch mal alles zugespitzt hat dass wir drüber
diskutieren können dass der dialog wieder in die
öffentlichkeit kommt und nicht einfach vom tisch
gewischt wird mit der bemerkung das soll jede
frau für sich selber entscheiden eben also der
bauch gehört mir das wäre für sie zu wenig ja das
ist für mich zu wenig bekommen die institutionen
nicht aus der griechischen philosophie also da ist
doch dass zum beispiel plateau oder so sagt da ist
dieses werdende leben ist schon gültiges leben
jetzt hatten wir schon bereit die griechische
philosophie jetzt mal noch vor bürger in judentum
da habe ich jetzt alles gehört also katholizismus
sehr sehr streng gegen abtreibung wir kommen
wahrscheinlich noch darauf bis auf ganz wenige
ausnahmen zb wir neben dass das leben der mutter
gefährdet ist aber ansonsten ganz trägt ich habe
da herausgehört die evangelische theologen die
sich seit sind sie sagen da gibt es doch noch
differenzieren uns ist das natürlich nicht kennen
dann muss die leben ist etwa dieser muss anfangen
zu diskutieren genau wie es im judentum also im
judentum ist konsens wenn die mutter probleme hat
soll man abtreiben die auslegungs spanne ist was
sind probleme da gehen auch die meisten also bis
hin in die orthodoxie dass es gesundheitliche
probleme gibt aber dann fängt es auch schon
an auch schon in der orthodoxie und dann im
progressiven judentums probleme können auch
psychische seien familiäre ökonomische also dass
man im grunde die situation der mutter analysiert
und guckt maas hat die für schwierigkeiten durch
dieses kind und wenn da schwierigkeiten sind dann
soll man ja das problem im grunde die sprache
aufzunehmen lösen ja ich würde interessieren
bevor wir jetzt weitere themen ansprechen die
mit der abteilung zusammenhängen wie sie mit der
bezug ist zum thema sie sind ja rabbinerin also
jüdische theologin aber rabbinerin in ausbildung
und ich denke sie haben selber keine familie dass
sie das thema von daher aus der berufspraxis sage
ich mal also alle also bei uns geht das ja
mit fragen und antworten an rabin sogenannten
response uns die enten eigentlich fast alle
damit dass der konkrete einzelfall der soll mit
dem lokalen rabbiner oder der lokalen rabbinerin
besprochen werden also es ist eben zum beispiel
grundsätzlich erlaubt oder eben eingeschränkt
erlaubt aber dass man dann den einzelfall mit
einer frau bespricht und das ist an meine aufgabe
in der gemeindearbeit von daher muss ich wissen
was in die positionen und meiner auffassung
ist dass religion einen menschen stützt das
heißt wie immer die frau entscheidet ob sie sagt
ich möchte das kind auch mit schwierigkeiten das
kann ich religiös genauso begründen wie wenn sie
sagt ich treibe ab das kann man religiös genauso
begründen so dass die entscheidung gestärkt wird
und das selbstbewusstsein des menschen im grunde
unterstrichen wird ich denke dass das ja die
aufgabe von religion wir menschen sie mit dem
thema zu tun es ist also ich hatte relativ selten
damit zu tun ich kenne eine freundin von mir die
viele neue rituale auch geschrieben hat es gibt
zum beispiel gebet nach schwangerschaftsabbruch
es gibt rituale dass man zb vergeht und so also es
ist eigentlich jetzt nicht so großes thema weil es
jetzt auch nicht so diskutiert es ist eigentlich
relativ klarheit aber eben seelsorgerlichen
einzelgesprächen schon okay valentin abgottspon
sie sind gerade zum zweiten mal vor kurzer zeit
vater geworden hatten sie mit dem thema mal
berührung oder in meinem persönlichen leben
eigentlich nicht meine frau und die mutter meiner
wunderbaren kinder ist kinderärztin hat auch eben
auf der neonatologie gearbeitet weitere ausbildung
also ich bin da ein bisschen näher dran am thema
hat auch diskutiert mit ihr ich bin ein fan ist
sie ist eine feministinnen und das gehört auch
dazu dass man diese themen diskutiert von daher
bin ich im thema schon drin ich habe aber nie die
frage stellen müssen mit mix mit mit welcher
partei er ihn auch immer also einfach das kam
nicht in meinem leben vor aber in diskussion ist
schon am ende mein fazit gewesen die fristenlösung
die es da und hinter die dürfen wir nur schon aus
praktischen politischen gründen nicht zurückfallen
also dass das dann eher so ein politischer kampf
kein keinen ethischer impetus oder irgendetwas
intuitives das mich da und manchmal auch klartext
reden lässt sondern ist so eine sache der politik
wie wollen wir unsere gesellschaft organisieren
wie sehr wollen wir dass die religion in solche
dinge eben reinredet genau dass die regelung die
in der schweiz seit 2002 gilt wie ist es bei ihnen
war aus da sie sind tochter einer süßen mutter
der tochter genau ich habe eine tochter und war
spätgebärende und von daher kann ich hätte ich
ihn die ganze maschinerie hinein kommen können
ich habe in basel in den frauen spital geboren
und bin dort betreut worden sehr gut betreut
worden und habe am anfang auch das mit meinem
mann gesprochen und gesagt wir wollen keine
invasiven tests wir wollen nicht weiter gehen
als ultraschall weil ich mir sehr bewusst war
sobald ich etwas weiß fordert dass auch schon
eine entscheidung von mir also man hat auch da
mal die nacken falsche an geguckt und ich musste
vorher den entscheid fällen ich bin schwanger
ich will fall scheint es ist toll und was kommt
kommt das hatte mit meinem gott vertrauen zu tun
ich dachte das ist wenn es behindert sein wird
dann wird die kraft damit kommen wenn es nicht
dann ist auch gut so zu sagen aber das war eine
entscheidung und aber ich habe freundinnen die
anders entschieden haben ich habe freundinnen
die abgetrieben haben und ich habe bisschen
mitgekriegt was das für ein regen ist und ich
bin die letzte die sagen würde du darfst das
nicht insofern stehe ich sehr hinter der auf
nächsten lösungen ich finde auch das ist eine
sache die wir als rechtsgemeinschaft in der
schweiz entschieden haben und das ist gut so
und trotzdem möchte ich dran bleiben und sagen
leute es sind keine steine und die frage dürfen
wir einfach so um probleme aus dem weg zu lösen
oder ist es nicht gerade auch unsere pflicht als
gesellschaft die probleme die sich stellen für
eine familie mit einem behinderten kind dass
wir da auch hingucken und nicht versuchen eben da
das kind weg zum schon da ihre formulierung eben
einen stein ja was genau wie grün und sie selber
haben von diesem recht auf nichtwissen nämlich
dann dank dass wenn ich auch noch ständig
genommen und da kommen wir vielleicht noch
das wird auch immer so ein bisschen enger wir
haben jetzt mal eine position aus dem judentum
und christentum verschiedene facetten bereits
gehört eine position eines freidenker es gibt
hier im haus der religion natürlich noch andere
religionsgemeinschaften da drüben sitzt säkular
marin kam er ist hindu priester ist hier priester
im tempel hier im hinter tempo aus der religionen
wie ist es denn im hinduismus wie steht der
hinduismus das sind ja viele verschiedene
religionen steht der hinduismus zur abtreibung
abtreibung ist eigentlich im hinduismus auch
verboten weil wir glauben diese wiedergeburt kreis
viele viele viele erwarten für ein new yorker zu
nehmen weil wir glauben es gibt 84 millionen
lebewesen am schlussendlich bei komponenten
menschlicher körper aber hätte gott gibt uns das
alles gesagt mit diesem körper kann man üben und
wieder mit einem kursrutsch kehren sondern häufig
erbrechen die wiedergeburt an und offenbar auch
das schöpferische der mensch sollte also überhaupt
nicht eingreifen da raus gibt es notsituationen im
hintergrund das ist so geregelt aber es gibt
auch einen situation bei vergewaltigung oder
schwierigkeiten für die mutter dann die mutter
ist so ständig am schluss entscheiden kann auch
eine gesetze geben aber man sollte auch achten
der betroffene ein problem hat bin jetzt auch
erstaunt weil von außen der hinduismus gilt ja
vielen als sehr offene religion vielleicht sogar
mit sexualität kann man super und so jetzt diese
strenge haltung zur abtreibung ja wie ich gehört
dass es nicht zu sagen ein stein sondern dasein
ein lebewesen eigentlich wissen entdeckt so lag
der gedanke das heißt wir dürfen keine lebewesen
töten und stellt man vor wenn wir dann mein körper
bekommt dass wir einfach so entscheidung schwierig
gibt es denn verschiedene strömungen die liberale
die offener sind oder ist das einfach mal einen
gemeinsamen nenner also hin versuche seine riesen
gebiet sogar indien noch lässiger es gehört auch
mit dem kultur zu tun und auch die hierarchie von
studium und das kann auch ein bisschen anders
sein also bei uns im hinduismus meistens viele
wünschen dass nicht eine abtreibung man muss sie
vorher denken einhaltung ist erlaubt wenn sie
dachten dann müssen wir achten aber ernst nehmen
und respektieren interessante präzisierung dass
sie bei der verhütung ist dann nicht so streng ist
wie kommt das bei ihnen sind sie auch so erstaunt
wie ich entspannt die spannung zwischen im prinzip
verboten ja aber wenn es dann zu problemen kommt
nichts bei der frau bei das ist ja bei uns im
gesetz ganz ähnlich nicht im prinzip eigentlich
verboten und ich hab's noch mal nachgelesen ist
zwischen zwischen tötung und totschlag glaube
ich angeordnet im gesetz ist schon ebenso nicht
einfach bei eigentumsdelikten zum beispiel und
wenn es dann aber hart auf hart kommt eben dann
dann gibt es eine reihe von bestimmungen die
sagen dann ist die frau diejenige die es ist ja
tatsächlich so in der schweiz ist abtreibung also
schwangerschaftsabbruch ist nicht einfach lecker
es ist straffrei unter denen und denen bedingungen
und eben teilweise sind auch nach der zwölften
woche wenn eben gewisse gesundheitliche dinge
gewisse medizinische indikationen das vorsehen
und es gibt diesen spruch der kommt aus dem
englischen schwangerschafts abbrüche oder eben
abtreibungen sollten straffrei sein sicher also
gesund und möglichst treu und das ist auch meine
meinung ich bin nicht dafür dass man abtreibung
als verhütungsmittel sieht denn das ist jedes mal
es ist auch ein eingriff es ist eine medizinische
prozeduren die kann bei frauen auch etwas auslösen
es ist es nicht einfach nichts und deswegen bin
ich auch dermaßen kritisch gegenüber gerade der
katholischen kirche die daneben verhütungsmittel
nicht mal in der ehe haben möchte also kupfer
damme wie soll das zusammengehen das erzählt
die katholische position erinnerte von orga
zeichen wie das wie das zusammengeht deutlich der
unterscheidung das ebenso sieht damaligen gab sagt
dass da die verhütung eben doch erlaubt ist eine
übersicht über die haltung der verschiedenen
großen weltreligionen zum thema abtreibung
finden sie ab morgen online eine sehr strenge und
restriktive haltung zur abtreibung gibt es auch in
teilen der westlichen kirchen und bei christlichen
gemeinschaften wir haben uns dort umgehört wo über
15 jahren hat das stimmvolk die fristenlösung
angenommen seither ist eine abtreibung in den
ersten drei schwangerschaftsmonaten legal dennoch
machen christliche organisationen zunehmend mobil
gegen schwangerschafts abbrüche wir haben roland
graf besucht der theologe präsidiert die schweizer
sektion von pro life international hli morgen
0,1 millimeter große im block c und denkt sich
ja kontinuierlich untersucht und im wind sehe
was für ein fantastisches entwicklungspotenziale
massa neben versteckt denn mit der nano radix
ihr müsst ihr fantastisch jetzt sie würden mit
der bibel argumente es ist jedoch klar dass das
gebot du sollst nicht töten da gilt weil es habe
eine mensch ist farfan jetzt geht es aber auch
konfliktsituationen in der schweiz hat mir der
kompromiss vor der fristenlösung funde wie stehen
sie denn zu teilen es ist sich ein demokratischer
entscheid gefällt worden ist aber es weiß ich
wünsche dass sie nun denken stattfindet man
muss ein rating abfolge für frauen das geht sehr
viel depressionen - die ja sicher wenn man schon
unfallprävention macht im straßenverkehr
abtriebs prävention machen seit jahren
demonstrieren lebensschützer mit dem marsch für
schlappe gegen abtreibung wie hier vor wenigen
wochen in bern veranstalter der demonstration sind
christliche organisationen beider konfessionen und
aus freikirchen regula lehmann hat den marsch
mit organisiert ich glaube dass jedes leben
jeder mensch jedes kinder jedes ungeborene kind
er würde halt und das recht auf leben und dass es
nicht richtig oder ist es recht ich überlebe vor
anderen zufügen ich glaube dass gott als schöpfer
vom leben jedem level wert gibt und dass es
darum nur die menge kompetenz liegt darüber
zu entscheiden ob es an das lieber jetzt quasi
lebenswertes oder nicht ich hatte früh stelle sich
für das rückschrittlich und das sehr freundlich
zu setzen warum sie erhöht den druck auf frau
massiv sieht die fristenlösung kirche immer
wieder dass frauen sei das umfeld gar nicht
so komisch es ist legalisiert gambo abschnitt
der b wir wissen aber dass sehr viele frauen
später sagen die körper nicht unterstützt hätte
wäre ich nicht wo ab triebe will eigentlich kann
ich das gar nicht von mir aus würde ja faust
auch die fristenlösung frauenfeindlich oder
fortschrittlich das ist natürlich ein ganz
spezifisches milieu in der wahrscheinlich
frau lehmann ihre gesprächspartnerinnen findet
die sagen ich werde ich hätte nicht abgetrieben
und ich werde gedrängt nein ich finde es ist
ein stück regelung in einem gebiet was vorher
ganz schwierig ungeregelt war zwar nicht so dass
es vorher keine abtreibungen gar es ist ja nicht
so dass erst wenn im gesetz ist legal ist dass es
dann passiert im gegenteil dass da die möglichkeit
darüber zu sprechen ist klar zu regeln dass an
spitälern von ausgebildeten ärztinnen und ärzten
durchzuführen und nicht in einem hinterhof und
vor allem eben es ist eine möglichkeit darüber
dass zum zum dialog zu bringen und es die frauen
entscheiden sich eher nicht im stillen kämmerlein
okay jetzt frage ich habe und dann gehen sie
sondern es ist verbunden mit einem gespräch mit
beratung mit information und insofern ein da kann
ich nicht zustimmen dass das ein rückschritt sein
das milieu das aus dem diese ideen kommen die
haben ja auch jetzt so aktuell ist das narrativ
dieses pps zu lancieren und ich sag' das jetzt
ein bisschen polemisch post aus orangen sensor
und da wird jetzt postuliert dass es spezifische
posttraumatische belastungsstörungen gibt wegen
abtreibung das lässt sich medizinisch eigentlich
noch nicht eben wie festnahmen das ist weder dem
dsm noch im city oder so drin ich werfe diesen
leuten teilweise auch vor dass sie sowas sogar
begrüßen ähnlich wie leute wie bischof lowe kommen
und sagen ja homosexualität ist heilbar und jungen
die leiden ja da sage ich zurück weswegen leiten
sie teilweise wegen eure intoleranz und beile
denen einredet es sei schlimm noch einmal
ich bin nicht dafür dass man abtreibungen
wie eine verhütungsmittel anwendet aber den frauen
teilweise noch ein schlechtes gewissen machen und
ein reden also ich habe auch schon mit leuten
kontakt gehabt bei denen ich das also nicht nur
annehmen musste dass sie das fass begrüßen dass
es den frauen ein bisschen schlecht geht sondern
da da hatte ich also wirklich belege dafür nur
zufrieden lösung vielleicht ist wichtig mal auch
eine zahl zu sagen es waren ungefähr 12.000
abtreibungen im jahr vor der einführung jetzt
sind es ungefähr 10.000 im jahr wir haben einen
rückgang wenn wir die wachsende wohnbevölkerung
dazu zählen könnte ich sagen es ist ein leichter
rückgang andererseits 10.000 sind immer noch
viel aber das ist ja ein symptom davon dass die
meisten auch jungen menschen die eben sexuell
aktiv werden eine einigermaßen gute aufklärung
sexualaufklärung haben und zweitens einen zugang
zu verhütungsmitteln man sieht ja genau in jenen
ländern in denen das restriktiv gehandhabt wird
in den abtreibungen verboten sind teilweise sogar
ein verhütungsmittel verfemt sind oder eben die
religion speziell die katholische kirche noch den
finger drauf halten kann sagen kondome sind des
teufels da hat man dann einfach viele ungewollte
schwangerschaften also das mittel gegen zu viele
abtreibungen ist meiner meinung nach eben kein
zurück kommen auf diese fristenlösung sondern eine
gute ausbildung auch eben in der staatsschule über
einen verantwortungsvollen umgang mit sexualität
also es ist nicht euer re kontraproduktiv ich
muss es annehmen ja irland jede land das gerade
gerade gelockert also früher mussten ja irische
mädchen und frauen junge frauen die mussten nach
london fliegen um um eine abtreibung machen
zu können und irland hat jetzt das blasphemie
verbot gekippt es das war vor 20 jahren war
das noch das war schlimmer als das oberwallis
teilweise also dieses er lang und das hat jetzt
eine riesen entwicklung gemacht also blasphemie
verbot weg und abtreibung liberalisiert chapeau
wir wissen doch unsachgemäße abtreibung ist eine
der häufigsten todesursachen weltweit für frauen
also das würde ich schon auch das fieber sowie
hintergrund haben sie das vorher gemerkt genau das
ist das geht gar nicht also das abdrängen dann die
die illegalität durch verbot es ist das gebot
angeklungen du sollst nicht töten bei dem einen
ethiker und theologen was sagen sie dazu steht
ja in der hebräischen bibel ohne zu übersetzungen
die nicht allgemein da steht da steht ja nicht
lothar ob du sollst nicht töten sondern da steht
alle tiere zach du sollst nicht morden töten darf
man um zum beispiel ein beispiel zu nehmen hier
aus unserem thema wenn jetzt da hinten jemand
kommt mit einem gewehr und ich sehe dass und
ich hätte hier zufällig auch eins drauf ich töten
um unschuldiges blutvergießen zu verhindern also
man es gibt situationen wo ich töten muss so die
ganze aber eben in den zehn geboten da stehst du
sollst nicht morden also das was der da hinten
tun würde wenn er das stünde das war mord und
das soll man nicht sie haben sie angedeutet es
gibt eine stelle im in der hebräischen bibel im
alten testament oder im ersten testament sagen wir
da geht es um diese frage sie haben es gesagt auge
um auge ich habe aus gehört da geht es eigentlich
um eine limitierung der gewalt und nicht wie wir
erwarten würden wenn mir jemand einen zaun raus
schlägt würde ich ihm wahrscheinlich mehrere zähne
ausschlagen oder als eine limitierung der gewalt
aber was gewinnen wir nochmal für das thema ab 3
als vielleicht auch zu dem was wir gerade in
dem film gesehen haben das erschien mir sehr
passiv also gott schafft leben und dass ich
bin das opfer von dieser schöpfung das ist
ja eigentlich nicht so sondern zum beispiel gott
schafft sechs werktage und das den schabbat wird
muss ich machen oder gott schafft den menschen
und die beschneidung machen wir also die welt ist
geschaffen aber sie muss weiterentwickelt werden
da ist wir sind als menschen mitarbeiter in gottes
schöpfung und durch die heutigen fragen sind
entscheidungen halt anders also früher konnte man
nicht wissen ob ein kind behindert geboren wird
oder nicht heute habe ich diese entscheidung und
ich treffe diese entscheidung einerseits mit dem
was ich am anfang gesagt hab hohe heiligkeit des
lebens aber gleichzeitig bin ich mit beteiligt an
der schöpfung und kann entscheiden das macht uns
als menschen ja aus und ja und diese entscheidung
die sie begleiten wir dann im gespräch und oder
wie immer sie dann fällt bleiben ist eine frage
die eine geschichte hat oder die debatten sind alt
über diese frage der abtreibung die frage hält
aber ein neues gewicht oder neue dringlichkeit
durch neue genetische untersuchungen durch
bluttests ein paar milliliter blut der werdenden
mutter genügen daraus lässt sich das erbgut des
embryos analysieren neben möglichen behinderungen
und erbkrankheiten auch das geschlecht schon ab
der siebten schwangerschaftswoche wenn der embryo
nicht das gewünschte geschlecht hat bleiben so
mehrere wochen für eine abtreibung gentests sind
bei schwangeren frauen groß in mode bestätigt
gynäkologe daniel surbeck vom berner inselspital
und er weiß dass es zu abtreibungen kommt weil das
kind das falsche geschlecht habe als dass sich das
linie minderheit wird das volk und abriss rundfunk
und das schauen wir hin und wieder habe dass er
die schweizerinnen wie migrantinnen und andere
ethnische hintergründe was schätzen sie wie viel
fell während das opfer pro jahr schweizweit ich
schätze dass es sich unter pfalz in orbit office
in der geschlechter selektion hat der gesetzgeber
nun einen riegel vor oben das geschlecht des
embryos dach den eltern künftig bis zur zwölften
schwangerschaftswoche nicht mitgeteilt werden
sp politikerin pascale bruderer hat diese
verschärfung angeregt mit diesen tests lässt
sich das geschlecht bestimmen bevor die zwölf
wochen frist für abtreibungen abgelaufen ist
mit der herkömmlichen ultraschall methode war dies
nicht möglich da bin ich klar denn einig dass es
nicht toleriert werden kann der gesellschaft und
auf unserer rechtsordnung das wacken richtigen
oder falschen geschlecht sbb oft gebraucht wird
oder nicht das geschlecht des kindes den eltern
bewusst zu verheimlichen verstoße gegen ihr recht
auf wissen kritisieren ethiker und es beschränke
auch das selbstbestimmungsrecht der eltern ja
diese neuen bluttests geben aufschluss über
mögliche genetische krankheiten aber auch über
das geschlecht sie gehen wir nicht automatisch
aufschluss und der arzt die ärztin kann dann
entscheiden was wirklich den eltern kommunizieren
ich hab das geschlecht unseres kindes auch
gewusst bevor ist da war weil es beim ultraschall
offensichtlich war aber es sei denn jemand würde
im ausland einen solchen test machen genau man
kann ja immer noch hinterfragt ist es ist viel
früher möglich oder ausschalten sie sehe die frage
was sind relevante eigenschaften die es den eltern
ermöglichen zu entscheiden ob dieses kind leben
soll oder nicht und das ist keine relevanten
schafft und wer entscheidet das eigentlich
gut aber jetzt haben wir das gesetz vor uns in
der schweiz dass es verboten ist in den ersten
treffer im ersten zwölf wochen der schwangerschaft
das geschlecht zu sagen wie reagieren sie darauf
also das wäre ein beispiel für eine schwierige
frage weil man muss einen guten grund haben um
abzutreiben also eben auf der basis einerseits
es ist möglich aber oder es ist verboten aber es
gibt immer ein grund warum ich es mache und diese
jüdischen response die sagen da im moment zu der
frage geschlechter auswahl das ist kein grund aber
zum beispiel genetische behinderung das ist ein
grund und bei uns begann eine ganz neue debatte in
den 70er jahren es gibt eine genetische krankheit
tay sachs die in der jüdischen gemeinschaft
sehr häufig ist häufiger als in der anders
sonst das ist eine krankheit wo eigentlich ab dem
sechsten monat oder so eigentlich das kind nur
noch schwächer wird also körperlich geistig und
dann nach drei jahren stirbt und da gab es fing
die debatte an und da war in amerika die position
dass man gesagt hat nein man darf deswegen nicht
dieses kind diesen fotos mit 3 6 ab treiben und
in israel hat man gesagt ja vielleicht ist das
auch eine spiegelt die gesellschaft wider dass
amerika eine freiere einstellung hat und man da
als jüdische gemeinschaft gesagt hat wir müssen
grenzen setzen und ein israel der andere ausgangs
bundes aber noch mal zurück zu der frage mit dem
das war jetzt zu einer möglichen behinderung zur
frage des geschlechts die mehrheit der nationalen
ethischen kommission in der schweiz hat gesagt das
ist eine schlechte idee dieses verbot weil
es wird dann eine gewichtung eingeführt wie
sehen sie das es ist ein rückschritt hinter die
den grundsatz der fristenlösung also bis zwölf
fragen wird nicht noch einen grund aber ich
habe jetzt eine realpolitische antwort gegeben
wenn man wenn ich wie realpolitisch weitergehe
dann sehe ich auch die probleme wenn es eben aus
einer religiös patriarchalen gemeinschaft
diese idee gibt knaben sind mehr wert als
mädchen also ich polemisieren macht jetzt ein
bisschen schwarz weiß aber grundsätzlich ist es
dann dass es gibt auch in europa es gibt eine
gute dokumentation über ich glaube albanien
wo dann dieses geschlechterverhältnis so kross
asymmetrisch wird dass man sich über die zukunft
der gesellschaft gruppe also gedanken machen muss
und da habe ich in meinem kopf zwei verschiedene
widerstrebende prinzipien also es ist ein dummer
grund wirklich eben nach dem geschlecht zu
gehen aber es könnte sein dass man gewisse also
wenn die prädisposition für gewisse genetische
krankheiten wenn ich mit dieser partnerin ein
kind habe ist es teilweise gibt es genetische
krankheiten die dann nur der glaube bekommt oder
nur das mädchen und da fängt es dann auch wieder
an schlauer zu werden wenn man jetzt weiß das ist
ein knabe der kann gar nicht von uns zwei dieser
krankheit erben also es ist auch da wieder nicht
schwarz und weiß doch sie sagen eben auch es ist
eine leichte relativierung sag ich jetzt oder
der fristenlösung ich frage mal weil sie jetzt
dass eine beispiel angesprochen haben albanien
sadiku mal damaliger noch mal zu ihnen in indien
ist das ja ein großes thema was geschieht dort
in bezug auf eben abtreibung von weiblichen föten
ein kind ist ein kind in religiösen sich
aber indien ist ein riese gebiet es gibt da
unterschiedliche kulturen es gibt auch ein kultur
wo ein mädchen groß wenn sie heiraten möchte dann
die eltern gibt so viel geld und ein kletterhaus
sie muss alles mitbringen wenn eine familie sehr
armut ist viele machen diese abtreibung wenn sie
verkenne dass auch einfache mit dem kultur zu tun
in indien ist es ja wenn ich es richtig gelesen
haben verboten dass das geschlecht mitgeteilt wird
streng verboten gleichwohl gibt es offenbar sehr
häufig abtreibungen aufgrund des geschlechts eben
bei weiblichen föten genauso elend illegal machen
sie auch die kontrolle und das passiert da habe
ich auch viel im medien gehört aber wir kommen
alle aus also meistens aus sri lanka damit ist
von meiner urgroßmutter so habe ich nicht so viel
erlebt also ich glaube dass es etwas mit den knien
oder bodenkultur ganz anders also in indien gibt
es auch einige regionen männer muss geld bringen
nicht nur frauen also das ist ganz anders also
wieder so eine frage wo eben ein verbot offenbar
nicht die gewünschte wirkung dann erzielt wir
haben gehört in der schweiz geschätzte 100 fälle
pro jahr vielleicht da bedeutender die frage eben
wenn es um behinderungen geht die absehbar sind
sie haben das aus jüdischer sicht geschildert
wie ist das in der christlichen sicht da ist
das christentum hat sehr klar bezieht position
für die schwachen und von daher ist es ein jahr
gerade zum schwachen und behinderten leben und auf
der anderen seite ich habe sehr oft zwei seelen
in meiner brust hier bin ich mit einem gesunden
kind einer frau einer familie zu sagen tja das
ist jetzt gerade eure aufgabe und ihr müsst ja
ihr müsst ja sagen zum schwachen das würde ich
gerne auf die gesellschaft zurück beziehen und
stellt noch einmal zurück auf die geschlechter
war das ist ja dann auch noch brisante man sieht
dass die rate der abtreibungen unter migrantinnen
sehr viel höher ist in der schweiz als unter
schweizerinnen dass bei 1 anderen migrantinnen
aus afrika zum beispiel ist es fast neunmal höher
als bei schweizerinnen und da die ganze kultur
ist es eine zu schnelle problemlösung wenn man
sagt die sollen einfach die dürfen einfach nicht
wissen ob es ein mädchen oder ein junge ist oder
ob es behindert ist das ist wirklich und da wieder
zurück zu den behinderungen glaube ich eine große
aufgabe für die ganze gesellschaft nur sagen was
er machen wir wie wollen wir gesellschaft sein
wollen wir das nur die gesunden schönen starken
ein recht auf leben haben und eben diejenigen die
ausgewählt sind oder wollen wir daran arbeiten
dass wir eine gesellschaft sind die gerade
zusammen mit menschen die schwach behindert
nicht dem ideal entsprechen die un wollen wir
akzeptieren und spüren lernen dass die uns etwas
lehren können ich habe meine schwester hat das
jüngste von ihren vier kindern ist behindert
und sie hat wäre erlaubnis gegeben sie zu zitieren
weil ich gesagt habe eben wer bin ich mit gesundem
kinder sie sagt ja und ich spüre wirklich das
gibt uns auch etwas und ich wollte es nicht ich
wollte nicht ich hätte abgedrängt das ist richtig
und wichtig sind wohin gehen wir wenn wir das
sukzessive aus merzen das finde ich ganz schwierig
soziale verantwortung also ich wollte einfach
betonen dass dann wenig mit dem christentum zu
tun es kann ein christlicher impetus sein dass
man eine solidarische gesellschaft in dem
bereich haben will aber ich bin da auch für
die solidarische gemeinschaft denn man muss auch
wissen auch das sind zahlen es nicht einfach nur
geburts oder gen defekte die zu behinderungen
oder eben schädigungen führen denn ganz viele
dinge passieren einem genetisch gesunden menschen
während seines arbeitslebens sport leben einer
geburt ja oder bei der geburt und deswegen ist
es nötig dass wir diese solidarität haben das
muss aber eben nicht religiös begründet oder
behinderter gründet sein das denke ich ist ganz
wichtig denn unsere gesellschaft wird je längere
gottlose also die menschen nehmen das nicht mehr
so als ein gutes argument war dass steht halt
in diesem heiligen buch da gibt es einschlägige
argumente teilweise aber es gibt eben auch das
gegenteil und für mich ist auch ganz interessant
und wichtig was macht denn die natur also 15 bis
20 prozent der befruchteten eizellen gehen einfach
natürlich also auch als spontan an bord ab bis
sechste bis zwölfte woche und da weiß man nicht
so genau also wenn man religiös wäre müsste
man sagen gott hat das abgetrieben und noch
krasser mehr als die hälfte der befruchteten
eizellen gehen vor der sechsten woche ab die
meisten frauen merken gar nicht dass sie dort eine
befruchtete eizelle hatten sondern denken dass
jetzt eine stärkere blutung und deswegen ist es
für mich ein nicht argument wenn man sagt schwupps
da kommt die seele reihen und jetzt ist das ein
dermaßen starkes schützenswertes gut denn dieses
gedankenexperiment wenn ich rein laufe in eine
brennende fertilität klinik also da wo man dass
das hat und da schreit ein einjähriges baby und
da ist diese kanne mit ungefähr 100 tiefgekühlte
millionen ich möchte diesen evangelikalen sehen
der diese kanne nimmt und sagt nein das sind 100
seelen drin und hier dieses kind da bin ich für
diesen reality check und da bin ich dafür einfach
mal karten auf den tisch und und genauer werden
uns voraus gespurt dazu seele wir waren ja noch
einmal zurück zur gesellschaft das nochmals stark
machen weil ich denke unser thema ist ja auch ein
thema wie ist unsere gesellschaft und ich würde
sagen wir sind leben um wieder zurückzukommen ist
verschiedenheit ich würde da nicht mit schwachheit
argumentieren weil ich glaub menschen mit handicap
sind enorm stark nicht jede frau ist so stark
wie das kind was ihr dann vielleicht haben würde
deshalb würde ich da eben auch lassen dass immer
die entscheidung der frau aber ich würde plädieren
dass wir eine gesellschaft sind wo jeder anders
sein darf und anderssein ist andere sexualität
anderes geschlecht andere andere fähigkeiten
die einen sind vielleicht geistig etwas anders
als andere er ist ein andersartigkeit und das
macht ja das leben überhaupt das so spannend
und wir können voneinander lernen nur weil
wir verschieden sind aber deswegen darf es
doch nicht nur die situation die entscheiden
der einzelnen frauen seien deswegen werde ich
mich so gegen dieses isoliert sein und sich
sagen dass ein reality check das ist gerade
nicht die realität wie viel gelegenheit gibt es
in einem brennenden in einer brennenden fertilität
klinik sich diese entscheidung zu stellen das
problem ist tatsächlich dass die entscheidungen
sind immer nur für oder gegen ein ungeborenes kind
das ist unser problem aber das darf nicht einfach
nur man darf nicht aber nur sagen tja liebe frau
deine entscheidung dein bauch dein recht das ist
eine extreme überform würde ich einmal behaupten
als einzelne frauen die männer und die familien
rundherum die werden da niemand souverän vergessen
aber diese quest gibt es ja und was ist wenn du
das kannst also ich mache man kann ja wer kann
ich das traue ich mir das zu und dann braucht
man eben schon gespräch mit freunden oder eben zum
beispiel in ein religiösen gemeinschaft und dann
am ende wie immer waren die entscheidung trifft
die ist so oder so dann stehe aber ich brauchte
der gesellschaft auf der ich vertrauen kann wenn
ich mich dafür entscheiden daran hat es auch mit
unterstützung genau niemand eben jemand das gerne
allein und ganz bestimmt ist niemand gerne allein
gelassen bei so einer entscheidung deswegen soll
so etwas mit bedacht geschehen aber man muss auch
verstehen wenn jemand vergewaltigt worden ist und
dann ist sie schwanger geworden dann ist es für
mich auch wieder eine ohrfeige wenn diese leute
möchten also wenn die er und noch einmal wenn die
könnten dann würden die ins gesetz steigen das
wird ausgetragen und dann von mir aus noch dann
sind sie gut ich ja dann darf sie das zur adoption
freigeben also da sind dann teilweise totalitäre
ideen mit religions- hintergrund man kann aber
auch eine frage haben sie gehören meistens
religionsgemeinschaften doch eben eine ausnahme
gemacht aber wirklich gerne alle fragen uns viel
liberales und deswegen ist es auch schön dass das
im moment oder mittlerweile eine raum strömung ist
das ist das schöne daran auch in der evangelischen
sicht ist es bei behinderung ein klarer fall für
das leben oder gibt es da spieler wie es im
judentum offenbar der fall ist in gewissen
strömungen naja ich bin ja nun reformiert und wir
haben niemanden der für uns entscheidet nicht wir
haben in der schweiz wieder einen bischof noch
eine wifi noch ein lehramt noch jetzt in meiner
meyer und tradition eine biblische aussagen würde
sagen können da steht ist insofern gibt's immer
spielraum aber ich glaube es gibt spielraum zu
diskutieren und gerade mit diesem nicht invasiven
vorgeburtlichen test wo er auch trisomie 21
getestet wird der und wo frauen familien zu
90 prozent wenn sie dieses testergebnis haben
sich für eine abtreibung entscheiden und s21
ist halt nun immer ein geburtsgebrechen ich finde
das was sind wir für eine gesellschaftlich wird
nie da bin ich sehr einverstanden einer frau ins
gesäß ins gesetz festschreiben dass sie auf jeden
fall immer austragen muss aber lasst uns darüber
nachdenken wie behindertenfreundlich sind wir uns
viel stärke völlig einer stadt kommt uns da
entgegen mitmenschen mit gerade mit sony 21
und insofern ja es gibt viel spielraum aber
lasst uns lasst uns mit dem bewusstsein und
ich zitiere nochmals den papst was wie lösen
welche probleme lösen wir eigentlich so und
welche seiten jahren das lesen den ball gespielt
wann beginnt eigentlich menschliches leben
menschliches leben beginnt wenn die
schwiegermutter tot ist und die kinder
also es war jetzt die bärchen war das ist
ein jüdischen witz wenn ich das richtig
also ich gehe jetzt wieder schläge von meiner
frau zu hause ich kann aber ähnlich erfreulich
dass beginnt wenn das kind das vestibül verlassen
hat und jetzt überall muss da überlegen was ist
jetzt das vestibül die gebärmutter oder die
vagina also allgemein kann man sagen wenn das
kind geboren ist dann beginnt das leben okay das
ist schon mal eine these geburt nein ich würde
da auch wir können also rechtlich mich in der
schwangerschaft war dass sobald ich wusste ich
bin schwanger war das werden des menschliches
leben das war ein jemand da drin und die haben
sie nach namen gegeben insofern war die geburt
nur noch ein sichtbar werden dessen was vorher
definitiv schon da war also da ist im judentum
bis 40 tage ist das wasser dann ist es ein teil
der motor also ist ein rechtsdenken ja und dann
eben bei der geburt ist es eine rechtsperson
deshalb ist eben vor der geburt da kann eben die
mutter entscheiden was sie mit ihren teilen macht
nach der geburt ist es ein eigenständiges
schützenswerte rechtsperson na ja und das
ist eher intuitiv in das teil kickt und mich
dazu bringt dass wir trotz übel ist morgens
aber was heißt das schon wasser dass da auch gar
nicht ein grund sein braucht also dass man in den
ersten 40 tagen das kommt so ein bisschen von
aristoteles und so wann ist eigentlich da die
seele da das judentum dann übernommen rechtlich
gar nichts eigentlich dann übrigens alles totales
hatte die lustige idee dann glaube ich von
thomas von aquin übernommen und die katholische
lehre dann geplant von thomas von aquin von
aristoteles übernommen dass die seele beim
männlichen vögel bis 14 tage reinkommt bei der
frau braucht das also 80 dass ein boxer langsam
auch wieder sexismus in eben alles totaler
gehöre eher auf meiner seite also das ist
ein problem aber ernsthaft man müsse sich eben
schon antworten menschliches schützenswert das
leben eben nicht nur potenziell also ich meine
bei einer spätabtreibung da das ist für mich
total eine andere frage also da wo die die die
schwangerschaftswochen sind wo das kind außerhalb
der gebärmutter wenn es jetzt einen unfall gibt
eine eine sectio eine note von sektion und dann
ist es außerhalb des dessen das gebären unter
lebensfähig das für mich ein total anderer fall
deswegen ich finde man ist mit diesen zwölf wochen
bei der fristenlösung ist man absichtlich an eine
sehr frühe grenze gegangen die frau hat zeit das
zu überlegen sie hat eine periode ausgelassen sie
habe hoffentlich zeit und unterstützung sei
dass in der familie oder bei einem arzt oder
psychologen oder einfach freunde und chrysler
stützen kann hoffentlich aber etwas so etwas
das außerhalb schon lebensfähig ist einfach
so weg zu tun da habe ich also größte mühe das
ist das argument mit dem verfolger also dass man
sagen kann wenn da jemand kommt und bedroht leben
dass ein fötus eben wenn das leben der mutter
bedroht in jeder phase also mein mann ist recht
des landes ist das recht also wurde jetzt in der
schweiz nicht irgendwelche religions- gesetzlichen
dinge und da gilt schweizer recht ja aber dann
ist da wo das hört sich ja auch ein leben aber
wenn die mutter in gefahr ist dass ich und wie
gesagt es gibt eine diskussion was ist gefahr
und da denke ich du musst sehr gut geführt
werden um der gesellschaft will um unserer
werte hinter gesetzt aber ich hänge doch bei
der frage des anfangs des lebens ist mir leid
sie haben wir jetzt wirklich überrascht weil ich
die katholische position liegen wo kommt ja das
christentum judentum dass es jetzt so offen ist
im judentum und dann wirklich eine punktlandung
also wie es der paragraph gesagt hat in dieser ein
spiel sequenz das einfach von anfang an also eher
verspielt weil von einer sagen also 18 18 9 ja
wir haben diese sätze gesehen also dass die seele
mit der zeit eben das wort nehmen es katholik die
serien sexismus bei thomas von hören war ja das in
ihren augen fortschrittlich der neuen entwicklung
ist die seele dazu kommt das hat sich tatsächlich
geändert jedenfalls in der römisch-katholischen
position mit der bestellung von anfang an aber
ich finde wir erklären sie diese unterschiede die
haben gab es auch eine ganz andere auffassung von
seele und weil die serie spielt für uns rechtlich
gar keine rolle von recom irgendwann vierzigsten
tag oder bei der befruchtung oder waren weiß ich
so genau wann die eigentlich kommt ist eigentlich
auch egal weil die seele ist rein die kommt von
gott und wenn der fötus zb dann sterben würde
würde sie zu gott zurückgehen also da gibt's nicht
bei uns ein problem mit ungetauften seelen oder es
gibt alles geht sondern auch nicht wir haben es
noch schöner will wir brauchen garten gar keine
seele also das ist sie brauchen medizin dass
ich auch mal interessante position von dem vom
medizinischen fortschritt abhängig zu machen wenn
menschliches leben entsteht also wenn es außerhalb
das ist ja mittlerweile schon fast 23 woche oder
so und der medizinische fortschritt sich noch
weiter entwickelt geht es noch weiter zurück also
eigentlich würde ich eigentlich nie eigentlich
würde ich sagen menschliches leben ist also ist
bei der verschmelzung von spermium und eizelle da
aber das ist noch nicht oder seele gesamte und ich
hab nix gesorgt von es ist absolut schützenswert
da wissen wir jetzt dass ich ein es kann sein
dass daraus ein mensch wird oder aber es kann
noch kein schmerzempfinden und in abwägung mit der
entscheidung der frau geht die entscheidung der
stau bis zur zwölften woche vor und bei all diesen
dingen ist eben mir ist auch die leidensfähigkeit
ein punkt und eben auch das mögliche leiden
der frau und mutter die vielleicht eine
risikoschwangerschaft hätten schon einmal erwähnt
noch das kann auch bei einer jungen frau zb die
die lehre noch nicht fertig hat entschuldigung
auch das leben der also das ist auch eine
chance sie sagen es gibt einen punkt oder eine
entwicklung ich muss hier anfang machen bei werte
doch am ende unserer sendung sind ja ein bettler
ich haben wir zum schluss noch die frage in die
runde geben möchte einfach eine kurze antwort die
religionsgemeinschaften können wir darauf zurück
ihre aufgabe wie sehen sie als gebot als verbot
gebe oder als hoffnung und unterstützung also wie
ich ja vorher schon gesagt aber als unterstützung
der frauen in der entscheidungsfindung also ich
würde jetzt nicht mal meine position ist die
gesellschaft soll verschieden sein also das
würde ja aber das kann ich nicht ja so wenn ich
ein seelsorgerisches gespräch führt dann geht
es ums zuhören und gucken wo sind eigentlich
bedürfnis zu viel fragen viel hören und dann
begleiten wo hindern die entscheidung ausgeht
dass ich die mit unterstütze ich finde es gut
dass religion ihr längere weniger rolle spielt bei
solchen entscheidungen ich bin aber dafür dass wir
mit liberalen offenen progressiven religiösen
strömungen die gutes wollen auch die helfen
uns um anniston uns steigern können auch helfen
mit sie müssen sich bewusst sein welche leute
bei ihnen im boot mit paddeln und das schlimme
ist häufig sind diejenigen die fordern diesen
lautsprecher haben und dann zu rufen abtreibung
ist ist auftragsmord die oben also wunder ist noch
nicht aus der kirche ausgetreten deswegen wenn
man sich von so was distanzieren will geht das
am besten mit einem kirchenaustritt und das war
mein wort zum sonntag war dort meine predigt halt
jetzt leider kann ich nicht aus der katholischen
kirche austreten weil ich da gar nicht drin war
und ich will dich dass der protestantischen aus
der reformierten austreten weil ich auch gar
keinen sinn weil religion schon jetzt christliche
religion ich weiß die anderen nicht dürfen sondern
weil das knie ist von der ich am meisten verstehe
den ich spielen schon eine rolle in einem land
was noch sehr stark von dieser tradition geprägt
ist ich sehe uns als unterstützer als ermöglicher
aber auch als erinnerer und herausforderer eben zu
sagen leute was steht hier auf den spielen einfach
noch mal lasst uns darüber regen lass uns noch
nicht zu schnell oder fahne steht ein gedicht und
ein eine zeile ist mir geblieben schnelle dinge
sind verrat lasst uns nicht das ungeborene leben
verraten das ist kein gebot und kein shampoo zu
einer einladung zum gespräch ich habe bei ihnen
frau birthler noch heraus gehört es gibt in dieser
position auch eine begleitung von menschen von
frauen die abgetrieben haben ja also es gibt so
gerade jetzt so im 20ten 21 jahrhundert viele neue
rituale besonders für frauen und lebenssituation
von frauen und abtreibung ist eins dieser rituale
da ist eine vielfalt also ich hab ja erwähnt es
gibt ein gebet nach schwangerschaftsabbruch es
gibt es rituale wo man dann in die miet vergeht
als reinigung und verschiedene sehr kreativ das
macht man in der gemeinde mit der vision ist nicht
festgelegt ist aber so das gibt es aber auch von
christlichen anbietern und von uns humanistischen
ritual begleiter wird das auch gemacht also dass
die pforte zum beispiel einen abschluss haben
können dass sie das würde wohl überdenken können
das gibt es also in nicht nur in den religionen
sondern auch bei weltanschauungsgemeinschaften
wie bei uns das sind also können und es gibt
ja immer wieder auch schwierige momente ja
also die wende geburt gewesen wäre oder der erste
geburtstag oder so dass man da im grunde sensibel
begleitet ich habe viel gelernt das war für mich
ein sehr interessanter punkt ganz herzlichen
dank für dieses gespräch annette büchler war dem
coach von christina ausdauer und saß iq berlin kam
ja nächste woche nächste woche geht es in der
sternstunde religion um den neuen kinofilm female
pressure um die sexualität von frauen genauer
um den kampf für eine selbstbestimmte weibliche
sexualität und jetzt geht es hier gleich weiter
mit der sternstunde philosophie mein kollege yves
bost diskutiert mit dem basler stararchitekten
herzog über die macht der architektur